we're gonna begin this hour with an
inside look uh at the hunt to catch it's
kind of an appropriate transition one of
america's most victorious serial killers
in 2018 joseph deangelo was arrested for
13 murders and dozens of rapes that
terrorized california in the 1970s and
1980s deangelo better known as the
golden state killer was caught by
detectives using public dna databases
similar to ancestry.com
and 23 and me it was among the first
times a technique was used to catch a
killer and the idea came from paul holes
who spent nearly 30 years on the case
working in the contra costa county
sheriff's office and the district
attorney's office in his new book
unmasked my life solving america's cold
cases he talks about that case and many
others the book is out today paul thank
you for being here thank you for having
me uh the book is getting rave reviews
people love it i love it it it's like it
starts like a raymond chandler novel uh
and it's like it's it's more
entertaining than fiction yet also
darker than the darkest noir
and it's got your personal life in it as
well that's what i like it's really so
how did you decide how to balance these
big public cases that story with this
personal story you also wanted to tell
well you know as i was reflecting upon
my career it i started realizing it was
important for me to write this book so
the readers can understand that there's
real crime behind this true crime
content that they're consuming there are
victims that have suffered there are
professionals like myself that are
traumatized by these types of cases and
so that's really what i was trying to
put out there and to put the personal
stuff in i mean that was a lot of soul
searching because i'm a very private
person and now it's like i'm opening
myself up to the world it's out and it
is out there paul but the thing that was
so fascinating to me is that you didn't
appear to realize the emotional trauma
that you were going through is because
you're seeing some very very gruesome
very grisly despicable stuff you didn't
seem to realize the effect it was having
on you no i didn't because as you walk
in and you see something horrific
you bury it i've got a job to do and
then i got to keep doing that job and
then another case comes up but as time
goes on and i didn't find this out until
after i retired every time i'm working
one of these cases and seeing that stuff
or seeing the emotional impact on on the
families it's a little nick and then
after after decades all those nicks you
start blocking out paul they tried to
tell you they they did you know and and
we should say you're married now i am
married now and i i i have the first
marriage and an ex-wife and both of them
have said and and indirectly you know
the relationships
the struggles
i wasn't realizing sometimes you know
why these struggles were existing well
the job had an impact on me well you
were doing the job for decades so it
would have been doing it well and doing
it well and finding all these people you
know it's got to be odd though too that
true crime has become just such a place
that people turn to you're even a sex
symbol i mean there's a hashtag hot for
holes what is the better hashtag
there's t-shirts you can buy all over
the internet you know
it is it i mean and what is
what does that say about about our
interests in these things well you know
i think
you know for true crime it's it is the
ultimate human drama you know and so of
course everybody's fascinated by the
stories behind these cases but also
what's interesting to me is that the
predominant consumer of true crime are
women you know and i've talked to many
women and it's like for them who are the
victims that are these stories are about
well it's usually women victims and so
they're like you know i want to know
what happened i'm empathetic to that
victim i understand i relate but also
how can i avoid that happening to me
that's right that's the thing but cold
cases are your thing you said you became
obsessed with the golden state killer
but cold cases are your thing what makes
you so good at this what do you see that
other people don't well you know part of
you know my career is unique having the
forensic science behavioral and
investigative uh knowledge wrapped up
into one person and so when i walk into
a crime scene i'm able to reconstruct
that crime scene based on the evidence
and then now i'm seeing what happened
between the offender and the victim but
other people have done that too though
paul
they do that but you know for whatever
reason i i think because i relate to the
victim so much and then i
disturbingly can put myself into the
offender's mind and see what the
offender is experiencing to help me
assess this case and who it is i'm
trying to find and then that goes back
to the disturbing aspects of the trauma
is
kind of reliving being the offender
wow you know
i'm curious you know so much of the
message you receive from from people in
life is just move on but to investigate
cold cases is the very opposite and some
of the cases you were working on weren't
even assigned to you you just were
interested where do you think that deep
interest in these old wrongs comes from
well there's there's really it's it's
it's twofold one it's the ultimate
challenge you know trying to figure out
you know who committed to this crime but
also i have become so obligated to the
victims and the audacity that somebody
took this victim's life
and then has continued to live a normal
life since that person doesn't deserve
that life and so it's go i went after
him that's what gets me about joseph
james d'angelo the golden state you said
he's a father a grandfather a fishing
boat in the driveway a volvo in the
garage right just your normal kind of
guy that's what freaks me out about well
in cases these these predators they can
compartmentalize their lives they look
like a normal person oftentimes they're
not who you think they are you know and
and deangelo is a perfect example and
that little quote there is a perfect
example of the tight writing in the book
it's a really great read yeah no no when
jamie said there's hot for holes when i
went to meet him outside and said we
have some hot for holes people in the
studio
he deals with the trauma
thank you very much for being here hot
for holes hashtag onmast is available
now